In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxarion, for September 28, on which we commemorate, our righteous
Father, Carito, the Confessor.
On the 28th of the month, we celebrate the memory of our venerable Father, Carito, Confessor
and Teacher of the Desert.
Our Holy Father, Carito, was born and brought up at Econium in Asia Minor.
The Emperor, Aurelion, in the years 270 through 276, who showed no hostility to Christians
at the outset of his reign, was incited by the devil after a while to begin a violent persecution
of those who called upon the name of Christ.
Carito, whose piety and godliness were well-known in Econium, was arrested and brought before
the consul when the imperial decree arrived.
As he fearlessly confessed Christ and his abhorrence of idols, he was stretched on the ground,
violently scourged and thrown into prison with his flesh, torn to shreds.
A few days later, after a second appearance at the tribunal, he was set free and took refuge
in Egypt until the death of the tyrant put an end to persecution for a time.
Having in his body the marks of the Passion of Christ Saint Carito achieved his martyrdom
by ever-grader zeal with which he followed the Lord in a life of Askees and renunciation.
Unlooked for trials came his way besides those voluntary afflictions by which he subdued
his body and made its subject and obedient to the Law of the Spirit.
One day he fell among thieves as he was going up to Jerusalem.
They bound him hand and foot and took him to their cave at a place called Faran, where God
soon executed his judgment upon them, for they drank wine polluted by snake venom and
died.
Carito was miraculously freed from his bonds and found himself in possession of the booty
amassed by the brigands.
He distributed part of these ill-gotten goods to the poor and part he used to build churches
to the glory of God.
He then settled in the cave himself and lived there in Askees.
While dwelling at Faran, Saint Carito brought many infidels to embrace the faith and to follow
the example of his angelic life.
But he wanted to find again his beloved solitude.
He therefore placed the best of his disciples at the head of the community and exhorted
his spiritual children to observe a strict temperance in food and sleep.
To pray day and night at the hours he had appointed them and to receive the poor and strangers
as Christ himself.
He then settled in a cave on Mount Dukas near Jericho.
However, he was not left to converse alone with God.
Many disciples came to join him and he had to establish a second laura before fleeing
once again to a place more remote called the Kuh.
He later settled with a few disciples in a third laura called in Syriac, Suka, or
the old laura.
But nothing could stop the flow of his new disciples and of pagans who came to taste the
honey of his words and to look upon this living image of Christ.
Askariton sought nothing but the sweetness of union with God in solitude.
He withdrew to a cave above the laura that could be reached only by using ladders.
He dwelt there for many years, taking water from a spring that flowed in the cave at his
prayer.
Knowing beforehand the date of his death, he was brought back to his first laura of Faran,
where as a spiritual testament, he gave his disciples to understand that Askisis linked
with humility and love towards all without exception is the sure way to arrive at union
with God.
His last word spoken, St. Kariton lay on his bed and fell asleep in peace to take his place
in the choir of angels and saints.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.